[Music]
Listen to the rhythm,
well, move your hips. Oh, let it pass, let it pass, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Oh, pretty, how pretty, let it pass, let it pass.
[Music]
Tell me, what rhythm is it going to?
Well, oh, let it pass, let it
pass. How pretty, how pretty.
[Music] Pretty, I'm a gypsy, I'm dark-haired, I'm the wild one, I'm wild, wild one. I'm a lover, lover, moon. [Music] I should
not. [Music] [
Applause] [Music] I
want. [Music]
Move your hips,
let's move our hips, hips,
I am [Music] warm. [Music] warm, pretty. [Music] pretty. [Music] Don't pass. [
Music]
Oh, moon,
me, moon. [
Music]
of the moon. [Music] Be,
move your hips, hips.
[Music]
[Applause]
Let's move our hips, hips. [
Applause]
Listen to me well, if a woman wants to
move her hips, she has to move them with
passion, with
intention, and with compassion. Come.
[Music]
Divine, divine, divine.
Morena the fierce lover
divine sister Quintana Morena the fierce lover
Quintana divine sister lover Morena the
fierce divine divine divine
div divine
[Music]
amte
herina
morenaa
amana
herina Mora